As with most major Marvel movies, fan speculation
surrounding the latest upcoming Spider-Man
sequel has been running rampant, with both
plausible and downright bizarre theories and
predictions.
Here are some of the craziest fan theories
we've found that try and predict the events
in Spider-Man: Far from Home.
Homeland's Numan Acar plays the cryptic role
of "Dmitri" in Far from Home.
While the specific details of Acar's role
are still being kept under wraps, fans of
Marvel Comics were quick to point out that
his character shares a name with a notorious
Spider-Man foe: Dmitri Smerdyakov, a.k.a.
the Chameleon.
In a recent interview with Comicbook.com,
director Jon Watts was asked point-blank whether
or not Acar's character was in fact the Chameleon,
and his answer was purposefully unclear.
"Well, Dmitri in the film works for Nick Fury
and I think anyone who works for Nick Fury,
they certainly have a mysterious past…
We're not specifically saying that he's…
but we're not not saying."
Given that Spider-Man: Homecoming included
the Vulture, the Tinkerer, the Prowler, two
Shockers, and even a brief glimpse of Scorpion,
it's not hard to imagine that Far from Home
will also feature appearances from multiple
villains from Spidey's notorious rogues' gallery.
If Dmitri does in fact turn out to be the
Chameleon, it will add an engaging element
of mystery to the sequel, leaving audiences
guessing who's really who.
Speaking of which...
Could the Nick Fury shown in the Far from
Home trailers actually be the Chameleon in
disguise?
This theory seemingly stems from the fact
that, in the comics, the Chameleon started
out as a Soviet spy with unique abilities.
Given that Far from Home takes place in Europe,
Chameleon's foreign origin could match up
quite nicely.
Nerdist takes this theory one step further,
stating that Fury's wardrobe in the Far from
Home trailers seems a little suspect.
In the footage, Fury dons the same long black
trench coat he wore way back in the early
phases of the MCU like in the first Avengers
film before SHIELD was deconstructed.
This is a stark contrast to Fury's apparel
in post-SHIELD appearances, in which he has
worn more discreet outfits.
This fashion faux pas could be proof that
this isn't the real Nick Fury, who presumably
threw all his cool trench coats into the trash.
This potential shocker could be the "major
twist" that Tom Holland teased when ScreenRant
visited the Far from Home set last year when
he said:
"There's a scene in this film where audiences
will feel like they were punched in the face.
Even filming it, I remember walking out and
then watching it again on the monitors and
asking Jon [Watts], 'Are you sure that's okay?'
And he's like, 'No, it's not.
People are going to hate this scene.'"
But what if the Chameleon-is-Fury twist isn't
coming.
What are some other swerves Far From Home
might pull on an unsuspecting audience?
One of the wildest fan theories concerning
the new Spidey flick is that we'll learn that
MJ, Peter's new love interest, is actually
the daughter of Nick Fury.
Possible?
Sure!
Plausible?
Eh!
We do know that Fury mentioned having had
a wife in Captain America: The Winter Soldier:
"My wife kicked me out."
"I didn't know you were married."
"There's a lot of things you don't know about
me."
Of course, in that scene Fury is on the run
from HYDRA, so while he said he's a family
man, there's no way to know if he's ever even
kissed a girl, let alone had a wife or a daughter.
Overall, this one seems pretty unlikely.
Speaking of unlikely...
In the comics, Ned Leeds is a Daily Bugle
reporter who undergoes a brief stint as the
supervillain Hobgoblin after being brainwashed
by Roderick Kingsley, the actual man behind
the mask.
Although the MCU's Ned Leeds is more similar
to Ganke Lee, the comics-obsessed best friend
of Miles Morales' Spider-Man, the name alone
is enough for some fans to have predicted
a dark turn for Ned in Far from Home.
Could Ned's switch to supervillainy be the
big twist awaiting moviegoers?
Well, the real issue with this theory is that
the Green Goblin hasn't yet been introduced
to the MCU.
And without first introducing that villain,
how would introducing the dollar store version
make any sense?
Then again, while we're on the subject of
the Green Goblin...
In Spider-Man: Homecoming,we learned that
Tony Stark had sold Avengers Tower and was
in the process of completely moving all of
the team's various super-props to their upstate
facility.
Unsurprisingly, a sale of that magnitude made
fans perk up their ears, prompting discussions
about the potential purchaser of the New York
high rise.
Additionally, in the trailer for Far from
Home, eagle-eyed viewers noticed that Spidey
swings past what appears to be the old Stark
Tower, only now it's under construction.
So, who could the new owner or owners be?
In the comic books, Norman Osborn briefly
took over the Avengers, recruiting suspect
characters to the team, including Moonstone,
Bullseye, and Venom, while donning the Iron
Patriot armor.
The team, better known as the Dark Avengers,
took up residence in Avengers Tower.
In what would be a crazy twist, fans of the
MCU have been theorizing that the so-far non-existent
MCU version of Norman Osborn is the buyer
alluded to in Spider-Man: Homecoming, making
him the future owner of Avengers Tower.
One of the more popular theories gaining traction
online is that Osborn's reveal will take place
in one of Far from Home's two end-credits
scenes.
The theory, originally posited by a redditor
who claims to be a special effects artist
for Disney, posits that not only will the
scene reveal that Osborn is in fact the new
owner of Avengers Tower, now proudly showcasing
"OSCORP" where the "A" once was, but also
confirm the rise of the Sinister Six, a team
consisting of Mysterio, Chameleon, Shocker,
Vulture, Scorpion, and Osborn's own alter
ego the Green Goblin.
This would certainly get fans excited for
the third solo Spider-Man film, which Tom
Holland previously confirmed back in 2017.
Although this would certainly be a satisfying
reveal, there's more than one famous tower
in Marvel Comics' version of New York City.
With Disney's multi-billion dollar acquisition
of 21st Century Fox finally completed, the
other logical prediction is that Avengers
Tower could soon become the Baxter Building,
home to the Fantastic Four, whose movie rights
were also returned to Disney/Marvel in the
deal.
If this theory is indeed true, it would pave
the way for the likes of Mr. Fantastic, Invisible
Woman, the Thing, and the Human Torch to finally
make their long-awaited return to the MCU
and suit up alongside the remaining heroes.
One of the most exciting fan theories about
Far from Home is that the X-Men will somehow
be introduced to the MCU via a parallel universe.
In the Far from Home trailer, Nick Fury explains
to Peter Parker that Mysterio is from another
dimension, inadvertently brought to their
Earth as a result of Iron Man's life-sacrificing
snap in Avengers: Endgame.
"Beck is from Earth, just not ours.
The snap tore a hole in our dimension."
"You're saying there's a multiverse?"
If Mysterio is indeed telling the truth about
his origin, he's living proof that there is
a multiverse in the MCU.
Parallel universes and inter-dimensional travel
would be some smart ways for Marvel Studios
to introduce their new toys to their already
overflowing sandbox and it worked in Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse.
That said, we're talking about Mysterio here
a supervillainous master of manipulation and
deception.
If internet sleuths really want to theorize
his presence here is somehow proof that the
X-Men are coming through the dimensional divide
as well, they should probably crack a comic
book or two.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.